[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nouvelle action coup de poing à l'opéra
de lyon déjà occupée par des
contestataires
ce dimanche en fin d'après midi une
cinquantaine de personnes ont profité
d'une assemblée générale pour se
faufiler dans un amphithéâtre objectif
de ces étudiants en art faire entendre
leur voix sur leurs conditions de vie
actuelles
alors ce qui vient de se passer c'est
que avec les occupants de l'eau est
occupante de l'opéra on vient de rentrer
à l'intérieur pour par l'entrée des
artistes
et on vient de prendre l'amphithéâtre
qu'on avait pas jusqu'à maintenant voilà
on a profité d'une ag d'une assemblée
générale
c'était important de réaliser une action
un peu importante avec de la visibilité
pour atteindre la queue pour puisse
parler de nos revendications que ce soit
celle pour nos conditions de
d'occupation à l'opéra et pour la lutte
en général coordonnée avec d autres
mieux culturel occupé en france depuis
un mois ces étudiants multiplient ce
type d'action ils se disent découragés
par l'absence de progrès dans les
négociations avec la direction pour
l'amélioration de leur quotidien
malgré cette mobilisation il constate un
manque d'écouté des décisionnaires
on a entamé des négociations n'a jamais
été entendu par la direction
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous a proposé un
abaissement des jauges et où nous allons
nous a complètement pas du tout laissé
la possibilité de faire autrement et il
se trouve que on sent ici il ya des
possibilités de s'arranger autrement et
c'est pour ça qu'on en est venu à faire
une action non violente en s'emparant de
l'amphithéâtre ici on se dit qu'il faut
absolument qu'on tienne qu'on résiste et
qu'on ait des lieux
de calme pour s'organiser et pour se
faire entendre encore plus une action
qui s'est déroulée pacifiquement et sans
dégradation l'occupation de l'opéra à
lyon par des étudiants en art s'inscrit
dans le mouvement national qui vise à
s'emparer des lieux culturels
leurs revendications sont identiques
prolongation de l'année blanche pour les
intermittents réouverture des lieux de
culture mais aussi retrait de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
sollicités régulièrement sur la reprise
des activités du secteur
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot ne s'est engagé sur aucune date
pour le moment
[Musique]